please welcome Adam pally
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay Adam oh that's nice yeah holster
there yeah yeah Adam let me explain for
the uninitiated I don't know what you're
I don't know what you're doing honestly
I honestly don't know you okay now we're
a new drum you have a you have a little
tradition if you like to dress up
different things when you come out on
our show last time you were here you
dressed up as fat Batman
and that was a did you get a good
reaction from fat Batman
absolutely not Conan was worried about
me your family was worried about you
yeah okay so so this time alright this
time you're on the show and can you tell
us cuz I honestly don't know what's
going on what are you today are you
choking to death in there worried that
you're dying I will say it is not
comfortable it's not comfortable one
should give Ryan Reynolds and after what
is this costume so I wanted to dress up
for you and every time I did I possibly
one last time I was a super here and I
thought that that was pretty good yeah
you know it's hard to believe them you
yeah I was like let's do another
superhero you know and raise the stakes
so I thought of this character named
snare devil - daredevil yeah devil who's
like that and daredevil but he have a
drum he has a snare drum and and then
you clearly thought well that'll never
work I won't do that
[Laughter]
kidding I'm kidding
so his snare devil so this is snow devil
but you know about ten minutes ago
I realized that on the character of
daredevil and the character of Deadpool
are two different characters and I
picked the wrong one I'm just dead like
that Deadpool with a percussive imprint
yeah that's not yes so this this was a
bit of a miscalculation you're admitting
now yeah
[Applause]
you're like some tropical lizard yeah my
first gut instinct is to vape yeah
now Adam are you into cartoons you must
be into cartoons no man
[Laughter]
okay so you don't like cartoons you see
superhero movies I want seen a couple
superhero movies but most of the time
when I see them I'm on an airplane and
I've had a xanax in a couple glasses a
Cabernet yeah to see is Thailand its
Cabernet okay tell me that the pink wine
is not pronounce the rose yeah okay with
the band the band loves you
[Applause]
would you like to talk here's my
question I feel like you're the carbon
dioxide has to be building up in there
would you like to take off the mask
would you would you be more comfortable
would very much cronin is it okay if I
take the mask off
yes you may take the matter
[Applause]
so what's happening so I forgot I forgot
to tell you that um like right before I
came out I I realized that daredevil and
Deadpool are different characters so I I
panicked and I threw on the this costume
underneath just hoping this would happen
do you have a whole daredevil costume
underneath there oh yeah yeah whole
thing and hotter you right now oh I'm
Miami 2020 the last days before it
becomes the ocean all right so let's
talk quickly I gotta say I'm catching
myself on the monitor now yeah when I
first told your staff that I was gonna
be in like a normal superhero costume
they were they're like that's gonna be
hilarious you're gonna look hilarious
that's a little offended you know and
now I'm seeing me and I'm like I look so
good in this superhero costume that the
only conclusion that I could have is
that my agents are anti-semitic you
think that they will not book you in a
superhero role yeah it says they're
anti-semitic there are no Jewish
superheroes
none of them we don't even have a Jewish
alter-ego I figure Robert Downey jr. is
Jewish he may be Jewish but Tony Stark
is Goya's hell that's a good point to me
that's a good point
you know what what Hollywood
discriminates against Jews yeah yeah
it'sit's it makes perfect sense yeah
that's what everybody says yeah yeah I
want to make sure I get to your your
project do you do you really what's the
difference you know
I think it's important to mention this
movie that you're in called most likely
to murder yes would you like to tell us
what that's about
so much I'm most likely to murder is I
play a like the coolest kid in high
school my favorite thing now is there
are people that tune into these things
late uh-huh and they're coming in and
they're just seeing you talking about a
pretty normal movie that you're in yeah
and this makes no sense
yeah doesn't make sense if you saw the
whole thing so you're right you're right
I I didn't realize that this couch was
red this used to be gray I would have
chosen a different superhero oh well we
did that because we're anti-semitic you
should have seen the way the pineapple
was arranged in my dressing room
I did not appreciate that shape oh come
on just having some fun with you yeah it
was funny so this is like a train wreck
huh I've been doing this a long time
yeah we've seen a lot of train wrecks
yeah but I do this isn't a train wreck
this is a derailed no one got hurt you
know I mean well I think I'm a casualty
no do you want me to plug your movie or
not
yeah the movie comes out sign to fail
yeah the movie comes out today on iTunes
go there and if you like the movie
hashtag most likely to murder and write
that you liked it because apparently
that's like just as good as buying a
movie ticket right oh okay maybe now you
like now I don't understand anything
about this segment I thought it the part
I would understand was at least you you
know plugging the movie and then you
just mentioned this thing that has blown
me away that you don't have to see the
movie just hashtag about it most likely
to murder we can't show the clip now
that's your fault dude mostly the murder
oh we do show the clip now
will you help me do one of those things
where you you get information to prove
that something is something else thing
where you find knowledge gathering with
evidence and google it where we like
charted book report yes kind of like a
book report like what the thesis and
everything but like when the police do a
book report God and Tara gation
interrogate game it's uh they need help
you work together use a magnifying glass
lose investigation we do an
investigation yes it's such a simple
word but sometimes those are the ones
that just like digital DVD on-demand
hashtag backslash jump Jeb flip-flop
Adam power
[Applause]
you